Mr Speaker it's three minutes past 12.
if somebody phones if somebody phones
999 now because they have chest pains
and fear it might be a heart attack
when would the Prime Minister expect an
ambulance to arrive
[Music]
rely on the Emergency Services when they
need them and that's why we're rapidly
implementing measures to improve the
delivery of ambulance times and indeed
urgent and emergency care but I'd say to
The Honorable gentleman if he cares
about ensuring that patients get access
to life-saving emergency care when they
need it why won't he support our minimum
safety legislation
foreign
the Prime Minister could deflect all he
likes but for the person for the person
suffering from chest pains the clock
started ticking straight away every
minute counts that's why the government
says an ambulance should be there in 18
minutes
in that case it would mean just about 20
past 12. now I don't I know he doesn't
want to answer the question I asked him
so I'm going to ask him again when will
that ambulance arrive
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker because of the
extra funding we're putting in to
relieve pressure in Urgent and Emergency
Care departments because of the
investment we're putting in an ambulance
call handling we will improve ambulance
times as we are recovering from the
pandemic and indeed the pressures of
this winter but I say to the honor
magenta again because he makes my case
for me
[Music]
the life-saving
people desperately need so why when in
other countries like France Spain Italy
and others why is he depriving people
here that care
Mr Speaker he obviously doesn't know or
doesn't care I'll tell him if our heart
attack victim had called for an
ambulance in Peterborough at 1203 it
wouldn't arrive until 10 past two
these are our constituents waiting for
ambulances I'm talking about if it was
Northampton it wouldn't arrive until
order Mr blister I hope you want to see
the rest of the questions out because I
want you to be here but you're gonna
have to be a better come on
Mr Speaker I'm talking about our
constituents
they were in Northampton it wouldn't
arrive until 20 past two if they were in
Plymouth it wouldn't arrive until twenty
to three that's why someone who fears a
heart attack waiting more than two and a
half hours for an ambulance
not the worst case scenario just the
average weight so from one week will he
stop blaming others take some
responsibility and just admit under his
watch the NHS is in crisis isn't it
well Mr Speaker I noticed that one place
The Honorable gentleman didn't mention
was Wales
no and the reason the reason that is the
case because this is not about politics
this is about the fact that the NHS in
Scotland in Wales in England is dealing
with unprecedented challenges recovering
from covid dealing with a very virulent
and early flu season and everyone is
doing their best to bring those wait
times down but again I'll ask him if he
believes so much in improving ambulance
wait times why won't he support our
minimum safety legislation
Mr Speaker he won't answer any questions
and he won't take any responsibility
clock our heart attack victim is in a
bad way sweaty dizzy
chest tightening
this is a heart attack in their shot
this is your constituent by that time
they should be getting treatment
but an hour off they've called 999
they're still lying there waiting
listening to the clock tick how does he
think they feel knowing an ambulance
could be still hours away
well Mr Speaker the specific and
practical things we are doing to improve
ambulance times are clear we are
investing more in Urgent and emergency
care to create more bed capacity we're
ensuring that the flow of patients
through Emergency Care is faster than it
ever has been we're discharging people
at a record rate out of hospitals to
ease the constraints that they are
facing and we are reducing the call out
rates by moving people out of ambulance
stacks and being dealt with in a
community now these are all very
practical steps that will make a
difference in the short term but I ask
him again and again and we know why the
reason that he is not putting patience
first when it comes to ambulance waiting
times is because he is simply in the
pockets of his Union paymaster
Mr Speaker this isn't hypothetical this
is real life
Stephanie from
Stephanie from Plymouth
was battling cancer
when she collapsed at home
her mum rang 999 desperate for help she
only lived a couple of miles from the
hospital but they couldn't prioritize
her
she was 26 when she died waiting for
that ambulance
a young woman whose life was ended far
too soon and I said Dad I can't even
fathom that pain
so on behalf of Stephanie and her family
well he stopped the excuses stop
Shifting the blame stop the political
games and simply tell us when will he
sought out these delays and get back to
the 18 minute wait
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker of course
Stephanie's case is a tragedy of course
people are working as hard as they can
to ensure people get the care they need
but he talks about political games he is
a
[Applause]
he is of healthcare I've already
mentioned what's been going on in Wales
is he confident in the labor run Wales
NHS that nobody is suffering right now
of course they are Mr Speaker because
the NHS everywhere is under pressure
what we should be doing is supporting
those doctors and nurses to make the
changes that we are doing to bring the
care to those people but I'll ask him
this if he is so so so concerned so
concerned about making sure that the
Stephanies of the future get the cares
they need why why is he denying those
families the guarantee of emergency
life-saving care
so that's his answer to Stephanie's
family
blame others never take responsibility
just like last week he won't say when
he's going to deliver the basic minimum
service levels people need Mr Speaker
over the 40 minutes or so that these
sessions tend to last 700 people will
call an ambulance two will be reporting
a heart attack
four will be reporting a stroke but
instead of the rapid help they need many
will wait and wait
on weight so if he won't answer any
questions will he at least apologize for
the lethal chaos under his watch
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
he asked about the minimum safety levels
we will deliver them as soon as we can
pass them why won't he vote for them
first of all but Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
we are we are delivering on the people's
priorities as we've seen this week The
Honorable gentleman will just say
anything if the politics suits him it's
as simple as that he will break promises
left right and Center he promised to
nationalize Public Services he promised
to have a second referendum he promised
to defend the mass migration of EU and
now we're apparently led to believe
I expect the from French just to keep a
little quiet because if they don't
there's somewhere else them to shout
their knowledge
Mr Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if we are going
to deliver for the British people people
need to have strong convictions but when
it comes to the honorable gentleman he
isn't just for the free movement of
people he's also got the free movement
of principles
[Applause]